(dramatic music)
- Holy cow, people, it
looks like we made it.
And 2020 is officially
coming to a close.
And Lordy, it was definitely
one for the record books.
While so many people went
completely bananas this year,
and some for good reason,
I'm thrilled that so many
of you have shared with me
how this show has become a
little oasis of sanity for you
in the desert of craziness.
As traditional media rightfully
continues to implode,
I'm happy to tell you guys
that "The Rubin Report"
is continuing to
grow and trail blaze
in this new digital landscape.
We expanded our
partnership with Blaze TV,
launched my weekday "Direct
Message" livestream,
and reached more
people than ever
during this election cycle.
And of course we did a couple of
tequila shots along the way.
For the last week of 2020
I wanted to look back on
some of my favorite moments
from the sit-down
interviews this year.
We had a ton of incredible
guests on the show
from Senators, Ted
Cruz and Rand Paul,
to new media superstars, Ben
Shapiro, and Candace Owens,
to All-Star comedians, Bryan
Cullen and Nicole Arbor.
I promise to continue
having the conversations
that matter as we
roll into 2021,
barring a full-blown
zombie apocalypse,
in which case I'll be
hiding in a bunker,
and it might take a little time
to get internet down there,
but I think that
goes without saying,
so now enjoy this look-back
at some of my favorite moments
on "The Rubin Report" from 2020.
About a week later, and now
I was off the grid already.
I was in the fruit section.
I was buying a melon, actually.
I do enjoy a little watermelon
in the summer months.
It gets hot here.
And there was a woman like
screaming in joy about
Kamala Harris, so I suspect
that it is Kamala Harris.
I'm guessing it's Kamala Harris.
The way you're nodding
at me, sort of-
- It is Kamala Harris.
- She is the worst.
- She's the worst.
I mean, she is the worst.
- Do you think-
- She is the worst.
- One more time-
- Do you think she
would have helped him,
or hurt him in the polls?
- Do I think that Kamala
would help him or hurt him?
Well, it can't really,
well first off,
the polls at this point-
- Who knows what he polls mean?
- It can't really help because
the Democrats hated her.
Nobody voted for her.
Nobody likes her, and
the the crazy lefties
that are running
the show right now
the Antifa/Bernie-coalition
of Marxists lunatics,
they all hate Kamala Harris
because they think she's
like a corporatist sellout,
but she, ugh, that's so gross.
- It's so gross.
- And it did look-
- She's the worst.
She's the worst kind
of authoritarian.
- Yeah.
- You remember that moment
at one of the debates
when she was still in it?
When the question was
asked to Biden about
would you use an executive
action to ban assault weapons,
or do something on guns?
And Biden said, people
can find this, Biden said,
"Oh, well it would have
to be constitutional."
And Kamala Harris
looks at him laughing.
And she says, "Joe, can't
we just say, yes we can?
(laughing)
And it's like, wait a minute.
You think that you can use the
power of the executive branch
to supersede the power of
the legislative branch,
on something that's enshrined
in the Bill of Rights.
- In the constitution,
yeah, yeah.
Like she's the worst, ugh!
- It's funny you mentioned
that witchy cackle,
because you'll remember,
this is the big problem
when Biden picks her,
she launched the most
vicious attack against Biden
that has yet been
launched this cycle.
She called him a vicious,
racist at those early debates
and said he was a
segregationist, or whatever.
- Oh right, right.
- Remember that,
and the bus-thing-
- The bus-thing-
- And all this-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Ridiculous things.
- So she goes on
the Colbert Show
and Colbert to his
credit, pushes her.
He says, "Senator
Harris, what happened
to Joe Biden being
a terrible racist?"
- What she say?
- And she, she puts
on the cackles.
She goes, "Ha ha ha ha.
"It was a debate."
And so he says, "Right,
it was a debate.
"But, are you saying
you were lying then?
"Or isn't it?"
She goes, "Ha ha ha.
"It was a debate.
"It's called a debate.
"It was a debate."
She must have repeated the word-
- And that's how evil
these people are.
That that's what
I'm talking about.
- Yeah
- It's all becoming too
obvious to everybody.
- Yeas, yeah.
- The nonsense.
She never believed
he was a racist.
No one in their-
- Of course not!
Right mind believes
Joe Biden is a racist.
- Yeah.
- But then you
throw it out there
and for anyone that's on
the fence about politics,
that's watching this happen,
it's like when
you see them do it
against their own
and it's a lie,
does it make you wonder when
they call everybody else?
Maybe it's a lie too.
- Right.
- Let's just talk about
the world as it is
at the moment for just a little-
- Do you "bleep" on the show?
- Oh, you can curse
your brains out.
But what do you mean?
You don't curse?
- I know, but if you promise me
you'll bleep it,
then I'll curse.
- I, yes, my people
will bleep it.
(bleep)
(laughing)
- I've been waiting for that
for a long time, Shapiro.
'Cause I've heard
you say, "Fuck off."
My guys don't have
to bleed my fuck.
They can bleep your fuck.
- Yeah, that's right-
- I've heard you
say fuck privately.
And then you put your little-
- As , as , there is a bit
of a gap between
the public persona
and in private
I cursive blueberry because
, that's, that's not
that's not a great
shock, but yeah.
- Okay. So yeah, let's, let's
just do it for a little bit.
Are we fucked?
Like what the hell
is going on here?
Right now.
- It feels that way.
I mean, it really does feel as
though any common bonds
that we once shared are
basically disintegrating
and that you're being pressured
into mimicking the belief
that all those bonds are gone.
So even if you believe that
the bonds aren't really afraid
and that really, we should
have some stuff in common.
If you say that out loud,
you're part of the system
you're part of the white
supremacist system.
And this is it's
such dangerous stuff.
And as we're sitting here
very, in the last few hours
there was a sort of
graphic that came
out from the national museum
of African-American
history and culture,
which is a Smithsonian Institute
taxpayer funded institution
- By the government.
- Funded by the government.
And it was all about whiteness
and the evils of whiteness
and among the evils
of whiteness things that
we've all integrated
into our lives because
of the prevailing system of
white supremacy, where things
like hard work, individualism,
justice, time management
delayed gratification,
science, I'm not kidding.
This is all in the document.
These are all of these are
all things that are listed
as elements of white supremacy.
That must be rejected
in order to move forward
into a better, more
progressive world.
And so all the things that
you would think like, yeah
I feel like we should
all have this in common.
Like science,
this one we should
have in common.
There's a whole
movement say no, no
all of these things are
outgrowths of an evil system.
And that in turn is a
the result of an absolutely
despicable redefinition
of the term racism
when it used to mean in
from virtually all
of human history
but certainly since the
1960s to what it means now.
So in the 1960s, racism
was what we all think
of racism as believing
in the inferiority
or superiority of a
particular racial group.
Right? Very easy definition.
You can spot it wherever
you see it, right.
I mean, it's not, not hard.
It's very easily
applied definition.
And then there's been an attempt
in the last several years
to redefine racism to
mean any system that results
in racial inequality
is itself racist.
And so if you're not seeking
the destruction of that system
you are complicit in racism.
And in order to be anti-racism
you have to seek to
destroy that system.
Well, every system in
human history has resulted
in inequality of some sort
or another because human beings
have different capacities.
We make different choices.
If you literally tell you.
- Are you telling me, we're not
all exactly the same.
We don't have all the
exact same thoughts
and gifts and skills
you're telling me....
- Stop being racist.
Stop it, stop it.
- Its slightly different.
- Ibram Kendy specifically
writes this right, and
how to be an anti-racist.
He says literally, any
system that generates racial
inequality is a racist system.
And so therefore it's not
like you're a bad person
because you're a racist, you're
just a product of the system
or you're upholding the system.
And in order for us
to fight that racism,
we have to fight
the system itself.
And so anything that is part
of that system, anything
and everything that is of that
system is tainted by racism
and must be ripped
down completely.
And if you are
complicit in the system
by doing things like hard work
and individualism,
you're an assimilationist
right?
This is what this is
what Ibram Kennedy says
in 'How To Be an Anti-racist.'
And Robin's Angela
sort of mirrors this
and you're saying
yourself, wait a second.
Are you closing in an awful
lot of doors to black Americans
and minority Americans?
Like the pathways to success
in a free system are things
like hard work, individual
effort thinking ahead
delayed gratification, like
this is not unique to capitalism
or the evil American
system or anything, but
- What are you
saying about black?
(indistinct)
- It's insane.
I mean, David Duke
write this shit,
- Right?
- I mean, you really could.
I mean, David Duke could write
the idea that whiteness is
about hard work and
individual initiative
and religious adherence
and family structure.
That's crap David
Duke would write,
but the anti-racists are
writing the exact same
crab and another saying.
Yeah. But all those
things are bad.
Right.
And if we just got
rid of our adherence
to these systems, well,
then we wouldn't really
have to have standards
that we hold people to.
And then equality
would be the result.
I mean, that's insanely
dangerous stuff, but
because the charge of racism
is the most is the most
highly charged charge you
can make against somebody.
It's the worst thing.
You can call somebody in
America and for good reason
because that is an awful
thing to be, right.
I mean, it's an awful
thing to say about somebody
it's an awful thing to be,
because that is such a highly
loaded term.
It's so easy to control
people into line.
All you have to do
is just to acquiesce.
All you have to do is
be the person who cheers
on the guillotines is the
guillotines chop off heads
and we'll leave you alone.
Now, we're not going to say
that you're left alone forever.
Right? That this only holds true
until the time
for the next year.
- What was it like for you
To sort of be someone that
was supposed to be talking
about the news, but also
for a lot of the time
you were kind of making news.
I mean, everyone knows the
what happened with
Trump and the debates
but that you sorta got
sucked into news too.
And in the movie, there's a
line where Nicole Kidman, as
as you basically says
that it's just sorry
- No no scherzinger
- Sorry Scherzinger
where she says that she
you basically saying,
you didn't want to
be making the news.
I assume that's pretty much
Yeah.
- Yeah.
I said, I'm not
going to be the story
and I don't
want to be the story.
and I was the story
after that debate.
And then I hated it
and I have hated being the
story every time it's happened.
I see journalists as
on the sidelines, not
as players on the field
and Trump to some
extent grabbed me
and put me on the field and
the Roger L's thing did too.
And then just, I don't know,
once you get your well-known
the sleazy media takes
a big interest in you.
It starts following you around
and they're not all bad.
Some guys are good.
There's actually a sweet
guy, right after I left NBC
all these paparazzi were
outside of my apartment.
And , I couldn't like
leave without getting.
(camera clicks)
and this one guy who was from
the post, he got his shot.
He was like, and then he
goes, "This is such bullshit
Megan, you can't say
anything anymore."
Like, there are real people
out there they're not all bad
but I don't like being
the topic of the news.
I have asked myself many times
why that keeps happening.
I think people aren't used
to seeing like somebody
they can't figure out
somebody who's sort of
unapologetically strong,
especially a woman
we're out there.
But like, it's not that common.
And I'm a woman who
doesn't mind fighting.
Right? Like it's
like what she doing.
But that I'm,
feudalistic by nature.
And I think it may be exciting.
It may be upsetting
maybe alienating
but for whatever reason,
it's attracted news.
- Yeah. It's funny to me because
as you're getting back into
the fray, like, it's so obvious
there's going to be a moment
like within a couple
months where something's
going to happen, like,
you're going to say something
or one of your guests is
going to say, sorry, psych.
And you're going to be like,
Ugh, why did I get back in?
But then, but then an
hour later you'll be like
this is exactly
why I got back in.
Like, that's just
the negotiation.
- I don't think that's
going to happen to me.
I mean, I do think they're
going to come after me
knives out, but I'm just
so used to being attacked
for everything I say,
it's like, at this point
I'm like, all right,
what are you going to do?
Are you going to
call me a mean name?
What would that feel like?
What would it feel
like to see myself
called something horrible
and every newspaper
in the country?
Oh, wait, I've done that in
a way it's sort of empowering
because it's like, they
took their best shot.
I'm here.
I'm well, I'm happy.
I'm about to launch something
that I'm really into.
And for once like, they
can't get rid of me.
They can't get rid of me.
Like even if every sponsor
I have is like, we're out
then I'll do subscription.
The relationship
will be between me
and my audience and
they can't stop it
whether they want to or
not, they can't stop it.
I will have my say, I will
have these discussions
with interesting
provocative people
people who go against the grain.
And if the audience is there
I will remain on the air,
- You speak in my
language sister.
I maybe,
- I know.
- I maybe able to retire early.
Now that you're getting back in.
- What do you mean?
We're going to go off
to the sunset together
and the digital sunset
- The digital sunset.
There you go.
So do you miss?
I mean, I think I
know the answer is
but do you miss sort
of the same blue dog
more centrist Democrat
because I think Biden was
the last hope of that thing.
That's what it strikes me as.
And clearly he's not going
to be the savior, obviously
for many reasons, but
Jordan Peterson talks
about this a lot that you
want this healthy tension
between the left and the right.
And it's like, look, I
know I'm new to the right.
So maybe I don't see some
of the problems that you
guys had been around.
So you see,
but what I see is this
pretty diverse group
of the real Trump people
the more libertarian people
that are all that are all
sort of trying to fight for
what the future is on the left.
I just see purging.
Do you miss the old school?
I know JFK is before your time
but do you miss an old school?
Democrat Daniel
Patrick Moynihan.
- Yeah, Yeah.
Look, JF K is a great example.
Scoop Jackson on foreign
policy who believed in standing
up to communists that...
You look at JFK.
I often quote JFK.
You read his speeches.
For example, what he
says on religious Liberty
you read his speeches
on cutting taxes,
where he campaigned in 1960 on
we're going to cut your taxes
and we're going
to cut your taxes.
That's going to produce
more jobs, more prosperity.
That's going to
benefit everyone.
Those speeches.
He would be driven out
of the democratic party
like some crazy heretic today.
You look at the tax cut.
We passed in 2017.
You know how many Democrats
voted for it in the house,
- Zero
- In the Senate, zero.
There was nobody.
I'll give you another example.
One that the media
refuse to cover,
but it's one that
I got very passionate about.
The Democrats introduced
a constitutional amendment
in the Senate to repeal
the free speech protections
of the first amendment.
Now this was following
the citizens United case
which citizens United
has become this totem.
So Hillary Clinton pledged to
every justice point's going
to repeal citizens united.
Joe Biden said the same thing.
- Do they know
when they say that about what
the Supreme court nominees
Are going to do in the future?
That that's not really
how government works?
- Well,
- I mean everyone does this
across the board, right?
- What interesting for
democratic nominees
that largely does.
So I've got a book that's coming
out in October called
'One Vote Away.'
And it talks about how one vote
on the Supreme court
can change history.
- Are you worried for a
limited government guy?
You don't want
the administrative
state to be too big.
It's like you can get
in the weeds on all of this
stuff, but in many ways
this is what you've spent
your whole life fighting.
That the whole system
has just gotten so big
and crazy at this point.
That even if you tell
people what's true
and we have all the facts in
front of us, that's sort of
the ship has sailed on reigning
in the things that
I think you and I
and most of my audience
are worried about.
- Yes and no.
I think if you were
asking your audience
obviously it's probably a very
limited government audience
but even if we were
asking a general audience.
So for example, if I asked
everybody in Kentucky about
whether or not a secret
court where you don't
get a lawyer should
investigate political campaigns
others that polls at 75%
particularly to keep
Trump out of it.
Now, Trump is pretty
popular my stage.
So it doesn't hurt so much
but really if you could
get Trump out of it
but the problem is people get
they won't vote on
principle and idea.
So I didn't get
any Democrat votes
on this only got 11 Republicans,
but I got no Democrats
even though many of
them profess to think
that Faiza has too much power
and shouldn't be
investigating Americans,
they wouldn't vote for
it because they saw it
as a vote rebuking
Faiza over Trump.
And so they saw it
as a political vote.
But I guess I don't
look at it this way.
I lose a lot of times
I'm used to losing
votes in the Senate.
And I think most of this
and this is where we
do have some ability.
So we pass out a sheet of a
prominent tweets that went
out from senators each
week on Wednesday.
And our office does this sheet
and they all complain because
we'll put out something
in my tweet will have
gotten 30,000 retweets
and they will put out Senator
so-and-so and they got six.
So one of the things they see is
that the Liberty movement
has reach well beyond them.
And they fear the elections.
These people are
afraid of elections.
They're afraid of me.
They're afraid of conservatives
because they're afraid someday
someone's going to wake
up and challenge
them in the primary.
And that's what has to happen.
The Democrats it's
sorta like this
Democrats don't care at
all about the deficit,
and they'll tell you
and they want to
spend more money.
They're honest about it.
Republicans say they're
against debt, say they're
against spending, but
they're also most of them
big government
Republicans vote lock step
with the Democrats.
So really when people ask me
who's fault, is it Republican
or Democrat?
I say, yeah, what?
It's really both party's fault.
But, we could give
up and just try to
protect ourselves.
But, I think if we
give up and the few
good voices year, go away, then
really, I think it goes much
quicker towards socialism.
It goes much quicker
towards indebtedness
and big government.
So I have to be some voices.
There needs to be more.
- I was strongly
considering leaving.
Like I was looking
at real estate.
I had a whole bunch
of people begging me
to come to Dallas.
I would have had a pretty
sweet operation over there.
My feeling right now is I
want to stay in fight here.
- I like that.
- I love So Cal.
I love I love the weather
of course and all that
but like I built
a good life here.
We've got friends.
I like it here.
It's a freaking mess.
Absolute mess.
I think you were at a bit
of a similar situation.
- I am.
I didn't think about staying
in fighting until I spoke
to you
and I've not, I haven't
stopped thinking about that.
And I think you're right.
I was just in Austin
looking at property
and boy does that.
Ugh.
- Well, I know we
probably, I told you
you were probably looking
at the same houses.
I'm on truly like, man,
(overlapping talks)
It's cheaper to live.
It's the I don't pay
that 13% tax or
whatever it is or 18%.
So yeah, I could save a lot
of money and what's
happening in California.
It seems as businesses are
leaving for just that reason
because it's very expensive
to do business here.
What California has
going forward is a very
diversified economy
and amazing weather.
And it's just a huge, important
state for a lot of reasons.
But California was
the state that worked
and we have a democratic
super majority.
And if you look at local
politics, it's just
anytime you have a super
majority of any group
I don't care if it's
Republican or Democrat.
I don't think that's
good for democracy.
Your vote.
If you are someone who leans
even a little bit, right?
Doesn't count,
save it, stay home.
We don't care.
And you aren't getting
elected to local office.
You're not getting elected
to government office.
You're not, unless you are a
pro big union across the board.
Good luck, good luck otherwise.
And I'm a member of
a union. I'm in STAG.
So I understand
the value of unions
but it's expensive
to do business.
And unless you can
push back a little bit
or come up with a
compromise, I don't
I'm not bullish on California.
And that ain't me.
I've talked to some very
smart people who are
economic animals and
all of them agree.
And all of them
are looking to get
out because it's too expensive.
Why what I live in on Skid
Row, basically, I'm in Venice.
I've been in Venice
for 25 years.
I love it, but I don't recognize
my town anymore as much.
- It's gotten really
bad over there, right?
- It's not just gotten very bad.
It's become profitable
because developers now can get
these government contracts.
I mean, I can build you
a bunch of apartments
for $200 million on prime
real estate on a parking lot.
And on the beach, if you'd like,
I'd be happy to that.
And we can just have, we can
create a homeless apartments
for people who are homeless
and don't worry about doing
drugs or anything else
we're not gonna put any
of those restrictions on.
You can come and go as you like.
So, there is something that see
this is not me, but a scholar.
I had a long
conversation with called
the homeless industrial complex.
Once there's money in bidding
and getting homeless
shelters for big developers,
you better be careful.
So these people need
to be put in treatment.
And the majority of the
people on the street
it's not a housing problem.
It's not a housing problem.
It is a mental health
and addiction problem.
And until we get serious
about that, we're
going to be in big trouble.
- Is it weird to you watching
it spread in different areas?
So Venice always had a
certain amount of that.
Now it's definitely
more, but like Hollywood
which also always had a
certain amount it's like
kind of taken over Hollywood.
If you just go to straight
up, especially now where there
aren't as many other
people on the streets.
Now, it just seems like
all there are kind of
like transient people and
homeless and tents and well
and as that inches
closer to West Hollywood
now it Lynch closer
to Beverly Hills.
And that then is it gets
pushed the other way.
(chuckles)
- They have their own
police force, but yeah
prop 47 and you can't,
it's not criminalized.
They're all kinds of these.
I voted for prop 47 because
the way it was phrased
and it had the, again
on the ballot as I'm voting, I
went, well, this makes sense.
I don't want kids to be
in a revolving door of crime
and police chiefs back it.
- Hell did you read
the whole thing?
- I didn't.
- That's it.
- I didn't have time.
I am remiss.
- That's how they get
you in this state.
I think more than any other
during the last election
there was this one thing
on the ballot about
do you want it?
It was something like this.
Do you want to put $500 million
into education for blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
And then there's
essay just a giant
crazy essay on the whole thing.
And I skipped all the
way to the bottom.
And on the bottom it says,
this can only be repealed
or reversed by popular vote,
but nobody ever says, okay
now we'll take the
money from the kids
but that's government
one, one, you sell it
exactly the packaging
thing you're talking about,
- Don't let it go away.
- Nobody reads the fine print.
And then you throw it back
on the people to be like, Oh
you'll have to
take care of this.
- Deal with this.
- It does feel like
we're sort of getting
if this is a video game,
we're getting to the big boss
we're getting to the final
boss where for eight levels
they've just ramped
up the racism, racism,
homophobia, blah, blah, blah.
And now we're there like
this election is it?
And, it almost seems to me
that all they've got to run
on is that America is racist.
And if they don't
have that, it's like
I don't think anyone
buys any of the policies.
And unfortunately just the way
the media operates right now
this isn't going to be
an election about policy.
This is an election about
basically racism and socialism
versus capitalism and
freedom, something like that.
- Yeah.
And Dave, the thing
that always strikes me
because I watched some
of the left leaning stuff
and God, I see this,
never ending clown car of
the black liberals that come
up and they may
talk about stuff.
So case in point.
So the McCloskey situation where
where this couple was
defending themselves from
from an angry mob,
who by the way
broken into private property
and on the left with
with the black pundits, this
somehow becomes about race.
And this somehow
becomes the idea
of these people inflicting
their white supremacy
on these black protesters.
Number one, those, those
processes are not peaceful.
Number two, they
were not all black.
And number three
the last time I checked
the second amendment
and the right to buy
arms is for everybody.
It's not just for white people.
So I'm struck when I
see these conversations,
how quickly and how easily
they removed all agency
from black people in America
and from African-Americans
in general, all
of our agency is removed
in these conversations.
- Yeah. Well, it's
also incredible
because they try to
paint the McCloskey as
as evil for defending
their property.
As we're watching all
this stuff burned down
but it's not like the McCloskey
is woke up that morning
and we're like, we're
going to go shoot people.
They had those guns
for a long time.
It sounds like they were
actually democratic donors
at least at one point.
And it's supported
black lives matter.
It's not like they
were just sitting there
waiting to start some stuff.
It literally showed up
at their door and they
defended themselves.
But that's actually a
good transition to media.
Cause you're a media.
What can I call you assassin,
I suppose as well.
You've just had it with
the mainstream media too
because this is the
stuff they're endlessly
peddling, right?
- It is in...
A lot of people don't
realize Dave that.
So I went to Columbia
journalism school.
I got my master's
degree from Columbia.
I worked in media production
for years before I
decided to come out
and say what I really thought
and do all this for myself.
So I know all the
games, dude, I know
about crapping sweet and
leaving half of the coat off.
I know what fake news is
because sometimes fake
news are actually most
of the time fake news,
isn't an outright lie
but more a half truth.
And so you see past
all these games.
When I first came
out as conservative
one of the first friends
that I lost got deeply
offended when I told him
and not in a
condescending way at all
told him that I have
been working in this
at that point for about
five to six years.
And I know these games
and you're not media
literate enough to see this.
And he got deeply
offended by it.
And then that was it.
And it just like it's whatever
but people didn't
realize these games.
And I think the deeper
we get into this
we see it over and
over and over again.
And folks like, like you and I
when there is an outright
lie and I mean a Whopper
it has to be shut down so
quick because if you don't
then it becomes part
of the lexicon and it
becomes common knowledge.
At some point Trump's
very fine people comment
which has been
debunked so many times
but it is Canon among the left.
And that's because, and there
was a failing on the right
because they didn't shut
that down immediately.
Immediately when they set up
- Fortunately we had suits
because we were supposed
to go that night
to an event that Ben
Shapiro was headlining.
And we were supposed to be
in suits for that thing.
Sorry, Ben, we left yet
to go see the president.
We go to Mar-a-Lago,
there's still
like an absolute insane
security situation.
And they have to like drive us
around a small
Island miles around.
Yeah. It was like
crazy to get in there.
We get in there
- We were like basically
almost strip searched
before throwing in the
back of a golf cart.
- Yeah. Like they
really am well,
it's the president?
And then as you've described
it's sort of like
the Playboy mansion,
but like doused in
gold hairsprays,
- Although it didn't
feel cheesy at all
it actually
- Felt kind of classy or
old school or something.
And we go in and there's
a main dining room.
And I'd say there were
probably about 50 people
in the main dining room and
Candace Owens was there.
And a couple other people
that we sort of knew.
And we were sort of whisked
into the side room, which is
I guess the more exclusive
room where there's
maybe 20 people and
our tables right.
In the middle of just
- An extra layer of secret
services to get into that room.
- And they make sure no phones,
no pictures, blah, blah, blah.
Our tables like literally
in the center of the room.
So the four of us
have a nice dinner
and sitting next to us one table
over is president Trump and
Melania and Rudy Giuliani.
And they have two other two
or three other people there.
And we have a great dinner.
We had a great time, right?
Like totally fun.
And Don doesn't drink,
and some one funny
thing was happening
but somehow the
way we were sitting
I kept drinking your wine.
So basically I had like seven
glasses of wine by the end.
(overlapping talks)
- Until I realized
what was happening.
It's because you're a lefty.
- Oh, that's what it was.
- See what I did
here actually today
because this isn't a real shoot.
I let you have your
water on your left side.
Normally I make the
water on that side.
- People say, I lost.
They say I lost them.
I left he Craig,
look at that anyway.
Then at the end of the
meal, junior says, Hey
- Actually going to
take some of your water?
- Go crazy.
Junior says, "Hey, do
you want to meet my dad?"
I was like, all right.
Yeah, let's meet your dad.
So we'd go up to him.
And remember, this is like two
or three days after impeachment
had just been announced
which feels like another
lifetime ago at this point.
And everyone, every story was
about Trump is freaking out.
Walls are closing in and
he's a paranoid lunatic.
The guy sitting there,
he had no tie on.
He looked totally relaxed.
His hair was a little more
disheveled than usual.
He was having a ball.
They were laughing.
- If you were
living on the moon.
You didn't know who
Donald Trump was.
You didn't know who the
president of United States was.
And all of a sudden
you found yourself
in this room and
they said to you
the president of the United
States is in this room.
Who do you think it is?
I guarantee you, you would
never think it was him.
This guy was sitting
there pretty quiet
for the most of dinner,
just listening to other people
listening to his wife
speak mostly actually.
And it was...
I was expecting this like
loud bombastic blowhard
sort of like nothing
even against him.
It's just, I think
everyone can agree.
Like he's you would think he's
would be the center
of attention.
Sucking a lot of the
energy out of the room.
The exact opposite.
- Yeah, it was, it
was the reverse.
So we walk up to him
and he's sitting and
Don Jr introduces me
and he says, dad
this is Dave Rubin.
He has a great podcast
blah, blah, blah.
And Trump looks look at him
and he's say, "You
I kind of recognize you."
And I was like, Oh,
well I go on Fox.
I'm on Tucker, all that.
He said, Oh, Tucker,
that must be.
And then he turns to
you and he goes, man,
who are you?
- Who are you.
Because I'm just standing there.
Like, I don't know.
- Who are you?,
and you go well,
I'm his husband.
And he goes, husband, husband
- You two are married.
And then he slaps his hands
on the table and he
goes, I want to stand up.
I want to stand up
and shake your hands.
I think that's great.
I think that's true.
- Turns to Melania He's
like, he's like, honey
these two guys are married
and he turns me.
He's like, you're too.
You guys are too good looking.
That's your problem.
You're too good looking.
And he's like, I got
to shake your hand.
That's fantastic.
And then he says, "You
know I don't give a shit.
He goes, and I don't think
anybody else does either.
And in a very Trump way.
And also, I don't think
anybody has for 20 years.
No, one's given a
shit for 20 years.
And I realized at that point
I was like, Oh, he thinks
that I think he's probably
a homophobe because I'm gay.
And that's what we've
been told by the media.
But I'm in that moment.
Like, I knew already
he wasn't a homophobe
so I'm not thinking that.
But I realized how
much does that suck
for him to have to preface
that after he meets
a gay couple to say
like you I don't care right?
Like, like we're cool.
- Right?
So you left Los Angeles.
I said goodbye to you.
And you said, I'm
going to Portland.
And I said, why are
you going to Portland?
And I think you said, I
need to see it for myself.
So you went up to Portland,
what'd you see up in Portland?
- I slightly shot my bolt on
this because I wrote a piece
for one of the papers saying
California is a failed state.
And then I went to Oregon.
(chuckles)
- Yeah. Portland is
some people say to me,
why do you need to go and
see this stuff for yourself?
And I just think it's, it's an
instinctive curiosity I have.
And I also, even when
it is exactly what you
think it is going to be,
it's still interesting.
Portland, Oregon was
exactly what I feared.
It would be, but a bit worse.
I was horrified by the
misery ration of the city
the total destruction
of all public monuments
and public buildings
the shuttering up of shops,
intimidation of the citizenry
the demoralization
of the citizenry,
a homelessness problem which
makes even California's
look minimal.
And the fact that the city
basically been given over to
an a misery to
lawlessness, I went
with Antifa several nights in
a row to pardon the language
a gentrification protest,
which was my first.
- That was your first one?
- Yeah it was, yes.
I've heard the too always
avoided the temptation.
I quite liked
gentrification, actually.
I think that how has
this being made nicer
and neighborhood being
smarter is no bad thing
but old fashioned view,
certainly not the view
of Antifa in Portland,
who sectioned off
some of the streets
and went through them in the
middle of the night, screaming
at the citizens and the
house owners telling them
they will all stay
on stolen land.
There's included many black
families, by the way, shouting
at these black families,
white families, families
of every background,
shouting at them
they were on stolen
land and should get out
- Were you Worried.
Were you worried
for your own safety?
I mean, you were
out there with them.
I mean, people know who you are.
- Yes. I was lucky enough
in the era of mask wearing
you can cover almost your
entire face lawfully, indeed
almost compulsively.
And I was, I mean, I've
been in worse places
and war zones where there's
more lawlessness than that
but it was not an, a
pleasant situation to be
in a what is normally,
a first world city.
The second night, I went
with them to the protest
to the ICE facility where
which was a bit Harrier because
they were assaulting leave.
So it is one of the very
few federal buildings
in the area.
They play a game of cat and
mouse with law enforcement
they get closer and closer
to the front of the building.
Their aim in the past has been
to barricade in the buildings
put burning dumpster
trucks in front of them
and then kill the people
inside by burning them alive.
So that's their modus operandi.
So you can understand why the
ICE officers don't want that.
And they get within a certain
closeness to the door.
And then the officers break
out and there was firing
teargas, pepper bullets
and all that.
And people were setting fire
to things in the street.
And that was a unpleasant.
Yes, it got shoot
out of an alley way
by federal officers with
a bunch of other Antifa
with me and the
officers at gunpoint,
told us please to move
out of the alleyway
and it was unpleasant.
But I have to say that
considering the situation
I thought the officer's,
whereas as decent and reasonable
and efficient in their duties,
as they could possibly be
- I have to read you,
there is a song that is
- I thought you were just
gonna bust out your glasses.
- Excuse me, sir.
Now that we're going blue.
- So there's a new song
that's taken over the world.
- And when I say taken
over the world, I mean like
this is the story, okay,
- This is the story.
- So I don't even know I
don't go blue on my show.
I'm very clean, clean, cut.
I don't wear socks
in my loafers.
I try to be, I
can't say the name
of this song without going blue
- Would it be better?
And you're hosting right now.
So I want you to do
what you think is right.
Would it be right?
Or if I just read
it straight up.
- I would feel
much better if you
so the song is
called 'WAP,' right?
W-A-P
It's by it's by Cardi B
and this song, I mean
this is like at
now the, the Anthem
the feminist Anthem, right.
- And Cardi B, I'm not
totally sure who she is
but I know she was like fighting
with people right before.
- Yeah. she supported
Bernie Sanders,
- She got long nails I think.
- I think she, and I
think that's racist
for you to say that, but yes,
she does have long nails.
So here's what this is.
- This song has just
taken over everyone.
- This is everyone's taken over.
- So I'll just, I guess
I'll just read a little bit.
- Yeah.
- Whores in this house,
there are some
whores in this house.
There's some whores
in this house.
in this house,
whole up.
I said, certified freak,
seven days a week.
Wet ass pussy.
Make that pull out game week.
That's good.
Woo-waah
Yeah. And then the chorus.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You fucking with
some sweet ass pussy
bring a bucket and
mop for this pussy.
Mop for this.
Oh, bring a bucket and
mop for this wet pussy.
And not for this
way, you got mop up.
Give me everything you got
for this wet ass pussy.
I'm going to not do
the next paragraph
because that's where
they'll come for me.
- Yeah. This is the..
- So where does she get her mop?
- Yeah. You can't, it's
got some words that you
can't say out loud.
- So that song, I mean,
she's making a point.
It's not without merit.
- No, it's not.
It actually, the song
actually does have a point.
The thesis of the song is that
all women are prostitutes.
That's actually the thesis.
She says, yeah, I got my
man by and she describes
sexual acts that I know, look,
we're young hip millennials.
Okay. We've done also like that.
You've never thought of, I
mean, in this kind of it's
I didn't know that pornography.
- Having a slop bucket when
you're...
(chuckles)
Exactly just that image
And I only got,
I didn't know that that audio
could be pornographic.
I thought pornography
is only visual.
- Yeah. So she's saying that
Things are good.
Like this is how
you attain power.
- It's not, yes.
It's not, she's not
- It's so the
reverse actually of
what at least first wave
feminism was all about.
- Yeah. Yeah.
It's funny because it's
such a ridiculous song
but it is a commentary
- Hold on 'WAP'.
- WAP, I see.
And it, then it hits you.
It took me like a day or two,
I thought, Oh, as I'm
pondering this deep
song of grazing.
- Yeah.
- But that's it.
And...
So to say that calling
women prostitutes
and having them sell themselves
is empowering is obviously
a complete reversal of reality.
Like you say,
reality is on trial.
It's emblematic to me of
everything that's going on.
- You really do do
it through comedy.
Like, if you want to
tell people the truth
and not get punched in the face
you got to do it through comedy.
Right. That's, just
kind of the way you
gotta do it and that you
really have mastered that.
But I'm curious, did you
were you kind of
right before then?
Because I want to get
to when you kind of came
out for Trump, but
were you always.
- We both had our,
(indistinct)
- Yeah.
We had kind of similar events.
- But like, what were you before
did you consider
yourself liberal
conservative, blah, blah, blah
- Liberal. This is my
liberal sweater, by the way
at least liberal media.
It's just like fricking
CNN reporters all over it.
Yeah. 100% liberal, for sure.
For sure.
And then I actually had
a good friend in LA.
I was staying at her house
and we were watching CNN
or something before
the last election.
And she was like,
me and my whole
family vote for Trump.
And I thought she's
a crazy person.
And I literally thought
I probably can't be friends
with this person anymore.
That means she's evil.
She's a bad human.
Like I was like, are
you guys like racist?
Knowing her boyfriend
is a black man.
I thought it was weird.
And eventually I realized, Oh no
her family just owns a bunch
of businesses and
employs a lot of people.
Oh, okay.
That makes sense for them,
why they would support him.
And then I started
to see the unraveling
of all the things
I've been taught.
You go to enough
parties in Hollywood
you learn they're
all douche bags.
It's just, it is what it is.
98% the ones who live
in Texas most of the
time they're pruned out.
Yeah. But I started seeing
that every single thing that
these people pretend they are
they are actually
the polar opposite.
And I went, well, what's
the opposite of asshole.
I kind of want to go that way.
And I saw, I caught
even Jimmy Kimmel
I caught him multiple times
lying in stories, total lie.
And I actually was responsible
for outing him twice.
He probably hates me
in the last year because
I was like, wait a minute.
That doesn't seem right.
I'd go to CSPAN and watch
the full uncut footage.
And then I'd do a quick video
on it and be like, Jimmy Kimmel.
Did you lie to your
entire audience?
Let's see.
And he did.
And then he issued an apology
a couple of days later
on Twitter, he was lying about
Mike Pence and one of them.
But the more I saw this
the more I was like,
motherfuckers tricked me.
You tricked me.
- Doesn't it seem crazy to you
that you have to like fact
check comedians as a comedian.
Like if you would've
said that to
any like eight year old
who wants to be a comedian
and your job will be to fact
check comedians through comedy
you'd be like, what the
F are you talking about?
- Right.
You can swear with me.
It's okay.
I saw you tell Ben
Shapiro to swear.
I've told him to swear
multiple times too.
- I was being hosty there,
but I would like them to say.
Fuck word, yes I would.
- Just like just once.
And then we can put it on a
loop and turn it into songs.
Yeah.
- I often think now that
I've been taking some
of these positions that
aren't thought of as popular
or okayed by
mainstream or whatever,
that the only thing to
fear is fear itself.
And I've been thinking
about that a lot lately
that the more that I say,
the things that I believe to
be true, that happened to be
against the mainstream things.
The more I get over that,
because if you can get
over the fear, then if it's
true that we're on a list
and they're coming for us,
- Then we're on a list.
- Then we're on the list.
And by the way, pretty much
everyone's on the list.
And that's why there's
that famous thing.
they came for the Jews first.
It's like, we're all
part of this thing
but it's a very strange time
that you can show me some
of these things,
founding documents
from the United States
documents about saving Jews
during world war II.
And it feels like something
that's kind of now
- Only if people don't
find their courage,
I truly believe, and this is
why I think you're so powerful.
courage is contagious,
it is people.
Not everybody is a leader.
Not everybody is willing
to step out into danger.
to lose all their friends
or to whatever, but when they
see someone risk everything,
and they see them on a list,
if you can get them early
enough, they'll step out,
but the longer you
wait the worse it gets.
That's Bonhoeffer was a pacifist
was involved in
(indistinct)
coup, how?
He's a pacifist.
He said, there's nothing
else we can do at this point
because it's too late.
The people's hearts
had turned to stone,
and you couldn't turn them.
We have to find a way to
make sure that our hearts,
and the hearts of everybody
we know stay soft,
and see people as
people, not enemies.
- When I was on tour with Jordan
one of the things that
he would bring up often
because he would talk about
the parallels to Nazi-ism
to some of the authoritarian
movements of the day.
And he would say to everyone
in the crowd, he'd say
there's 3,000 of you
sitting out here right now.
And I guarantee you that
every single one of you
would think that you
wouldn't be a Nazi
if this was 1936 Germany,
and that proves probably
that you would be.
And I always thought that
that was pretty powerful
that we all think we would
do the unpopular thing.
We all think we would
do the risky thing.
We all judge everybody by
our standards of today.
- I'm not sure I'd
stand in the end.
I mean, a friend of
mine, Marcus Trell,
I said to him how do you
stand torture and not break?
And he said, Glen, everyone
breaks, everyone breaks.
He said, but the ones
who break the fastest,
and the loudest are
the ones who will say,
I'll stand, oh, I'll stand
because they haven't
thought about it.
It's why I wanted to bring
my kids to Auschwitz.
I need you to feel it so
you can think about it,
and really look at
this as a possibility.
And once you do
that and you realize
by the grace of God I'll
stand then you're ready,
but we have got to prepare
ourselves now to be ready
because if you're ready
now the problems go away.
- If you're looking
for more honest,
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists, all right, over here
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.